so many people wanted to know you know  Trump is known for like not getting a  lot of sleep he's just work you know  supposedly working at all hours of the  day and stuff how much sleep do you get  are you one of these very little sleep  like super high performance guys no but  I do when I do sleep it's quality David  you should have one of my pillows too  all right well I'll test it I'll test it  out I'll send you some pills and she'd  say well actually help you sleep  there's a reason we've sold 76 million  of them and you know what Mike if it if  it's good I will tell the audience that  it's the best one absolutely everyone  it'll change your life okay there's a  difference between time of spending and  better it's quality sleep but so how  much sleep do you get would you say  now I probably sleep six to eight hours  yeah that's good